before you tape homeland you go to spy
camp right yeah yeah
what's that like i think i want to go
with it you totally do want to
why is that uh so appealing and cool
and what is spike where is spike yeah
how do i get there
i
what did you need to learn well i knew
nothing at that point so everything but
i was really surprised by how
how candid they were
and
i asked them i said why are you telling
me all this and i said well
we're always recruiting and this is an
amazing you know
opportunity like right
for them so and i don't think that
they're represented all that often in
pop culture so they wanted to have some
influence in that so we we go to a
clubhouse um
in in uh in dc
and what do you mean clubhouse well they
have these clubs you know like uh like
the yale club or you know i think it's a
club for cia dudes yeah oh that must be
awesome and um for five consecutive days
from you know 9 a.m to
9 00 p.m sometimes later
we just interview a series of people who
you know do this now as an actress what
are you looking for in other words are
you trying to locate someone who's
like overall attitude you can
emulate or well at the beginning yeah i
wanted to just get a sense of
what the personal cost is to do this job
you know how high the anxiety is uh are
they
lonely are they that's how you get into
character yeah and then i told they told
them oh well this particular character
is bipolar and they laughed out loud
well because they're all so thoroughly
vetted you know that but you know i'm
sure there's some very eccentric people
you know well you're right because like
your character in homeland while bipolar
it brings out this brilliance so
therefore the cia might want that person
that's the conceit i mean i think we
pushed that too right but i do agree
with the cia in that your show makes me
think oh you know i'm a big [ __ ] but
i'm when i watch the show i'm like oh i
would have been great in the cia i'd be
like saul or something and i love how
sal is with you like when you're having
a nervous breakdown the hospital he
walks in and he goes
how can i help like wouldn't you like
someone in life to just say that to you
i love that i love sometimes he leaves
her locked up you know come on and then
and then you turn
thanks for thanks for coming here but
like what do you really want like it's
so great such a great i love you i love
you acting out homeland scenes but don't
you think he's the father you always
dream of he's just this guy who knows
things and he's calm and he tries he's a
good man yeah why can't he get a woman
oh
well it's a lonely gig right that's what
we're saying
yeah i think that's a big theme in our
show
you